du coup kaka
à madrid les européens joue à onze
contre onze pour l'union monétaire
malgré quelques bémols margaret cette
chère et contre nouvel accident pour la
marine soviétique au large de la norvège
un sous marin à propulsion nucléaire est
en partie détruit mais il pourrait
regagner sa base
ce sera finalement en octobre que les
députés plancheront sur le financement
des partis politiques le gouvernement
juge plus sage d'attendre la pub en
festivals à cannes
l'espagne le zimbabwe et singapour
nouveau roi du spot wimbledon les
premières balles sur un gazon plus que
secte premiers qualifiés hedberg lendl
et la française de monge
madame monsieur bonsoir une nouvelle
fois ce soir un sous marin nucléaire
soviétique est en détresse dans l'océan
arctique au large de la norvège
le bâtiment à propulsion nucléaire a
connu une avarie de moteur en plongée un
incendie s'est déclaré à bord selon le
ministère soviétique de la défense il
n'y a aucun risque de contamination
nucléaire
à l'heure qu'il est le submersible a
fait surface et attend d'être remorqué
par un bateau de secours soviétique vers
sa base
patrick esther un sous-marin vieux de 25
ans et puis le système de
refroidissement du réacteur nucléaire
qui se brise
il est 5 heures du matin l'équipage
soviétique lance son premier sos une
épaisse fumée se dégage du compartiment
moteur
immédiatement le réacteur est stoppée
tandis que le sous marin fait surface
puis essaye de rejoindre sa base grâce
au diesel de secours de nombreux
bâtiments de la flotte nord de l'urss
rejoignant deux heures la zone pour
porter assistance technique pas de
victime et aucun risque de contamination
radioactive s'empresse d'annoncer les
autorités soviétiques mais celle-ci ne
précise pas si le sous marin était mieux
armé de huit missiles atomiques de
conception très rustique
ces sous marins d'une 6000 tonnes en
déplacement
eco2 sont encore au nombre de 26 en
opération sur les 180 ou sous marins
nucléaires que possède la marine
soviétique
cet accident au large des côtes
norvégiennes survient seulement trois
mois après le naufrage un autre
sous-marin de classe mike accident qui
avait provoqué la mort de 42 marins en
disant huit bâtiments nucléaires
soviétiques se sont ainsi perdus en mer
et ce soir les autorités norvégiennes
annoncent qu'elles procéderont à des
contrôles de radioactivité sur la zone
de l'accident
l'intransigeance de margaret cette
chaire est devenu un rite des sommes les
européens celui de madrid consacré
notamment à l'union monétaire ne déroge
pas à la règle
on joue serré dans la capitale espagnole
à 11 contre une contre 1 la dame de fer
veut bien parler de coopération
monétaire mais certainement pas d'union
il a donc fait très chaud ce matin en
espagne devant l'inflexibilité
britannique
le président français a menacé de
remettre en cause la libération des
mouvements de capitaux au 1er juillet 90
ce at il dit qui ont accepté une
première étape pour les mouvements de
capitaux avaient forcément à l'esprit
tout la suite dans l'entourage du
président français on excluait pas non
plus négociations serrées oblige un coup
de frein à la construction européenne
le récit de l'un de nos envoyés spéciaux
georges bortoli rien d'étonnant or si la
police madrilène est sur le qui vive les
terroristes basques de l'êta sont
toujours prêts à frapper en toute
occasion et surtout dans les grandes
occasions
or c'est indiscutablement un grand
événement pour les espagnols que ce
sommet qui se déroule dans le grand
palais des congrès de madrid décoré par
miro entrée dans la communauté
européenne il y a trois ans seulement
l'espagne la préside cette année pour la
première fois au deuxième semestre c'est
françois mitterrand qui succédera comme
président en exercice de l'europe à
felipe gonzalez tout simplement parce
que dans l'ordre alphabétique
la france vient après l'espagne et comme
monsieur consoler ce monsieur mitterrand
devra faire face aux sourires combatif
de madame thatcher
le prochain pas de l'europe en effet
devrait être de se doter d'une monnaie
commune
or l'idée de cette monnaie
supra nationale fait horreur à madame
seule chair elle l'a dit ce matin la
séance plénière elle a redit au déjeuner
du roi juan carlos
elle avait changé de toilette mais pas
d'idées tout au plus acceptera-t-elle de
faire entrer un jour la livre sterling
dans le système monétaire européen qui
empêche les monnaies de trop fluctué
entre elle se contentera temps alors de
ce modeste pas en avant monsieur
mitterrand s'est quelque peu lâché c'est
d'après midi contre ces réticences de
madame seule chair en fait du côté
français du côté espagnol aussi on
accuse carrément le premier ministre
britannique de revenir sur des
engagements déjà pris déjà accepté et on
fait remarquer côté français qu'après
tout la france a donné satisfaction au
libéralisme de madame cette chaire en
autorisant la libre circulation des
capitaux
alors est-ce qu'on veut laisser entendre
que le gouvernement français pourrait
revenir sur ces accords de libre
circulation
il ya peut-être là les éléments d'un
marchandage vous savez que c'est jacques
delors le président de la commission de
bruxelles qui est à l'origine de ce plan
d' union économique et monétaire
indispensable libre circulation des
capitaux en 1990 et au marché unique de
explications de claire chazal 1979
valéry giscard d'estaing annonce la
naissance du sms le système monétaire
européen
un dispositif qui impose aujourd'hui à 9
monnaie sur les douze européennes de
limiter leur fluctuation à plus ou moins
2,25 pour cent
autour d'un cours fixé l'europe se dote
en même temps d'une monnaie de compte
comme une l'écu dont la valeur est
calculée sur la base d'un panier de 11
monnaie seule la drachme grecque n'en
faisant pas partie le plan de l'or lancé
à hanovre en 1988 vise à parfaire
l'union monétaire européenne
avec trois étapes d'abord au 1er juillet
90 une amélioration et un élargissement
du sm eu une période délicate à gérer
selon les experts nous allons vivre
quelques années un petit peu délicate
nous aurons à la fois la liberté des
mouvements de capitaux sans avoir la
solidarité monétaire européenne qui
normalement devrait l'accompagner
c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous pensons qu'il faut que l'union
monétaire se réalise le plus vite
possible
seconde étape la création d'une
fédération des 12 banques centrales
européennes enfin l'arrivée à terme dans
une dizaine d'années d'une véritable
monnaie commune avec l'instauration de
parité totalement fixe entre les devises
a madrid on devrait également parler de
l'europe sociale de la définition d'une
charte sociale où figureraient les
droits et acquis sociaux des salariés
mais là encore margaret thatcher
apparaît très réfractaire il n'empêche
la mobilité des salariés dans les
différents pays d'europe est une idée
qui fait son chemin même si pour
l'instant elle ne touche la plupart du
temps que les cadres véronique auger ils
sont restés quatre jours dans ces
bungalows tout près de paris mais sans
espoir d'y mettre les pieds pas de
voiture pas de télévision avions
conférence avions un séminaire très
spéciale réservée aux cadres
internationaux de l objectif leur donner
le sentiment qu'ils sont l'élite
on a dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour les
former et toute la direction générale a
défilé devant te la plupart des
entreprises de taille européenne se sont
lancés dans ces stages de
conditionnement ultime instruments pour
réussir le pari de l'expatriation de
certains salariés
mais les les équipes mais les cultures
mêlées les métiers et son de progrès ne
s'agit pas d'en faire un mouvement
perpétuel et l'anarchie permanente
s'agit de faire avec discernement avec
un bon dosage
il faut le faire délibérément ou
volontairement avec des vues
stratégiques
les volontaires étant peu nombreux
quelle que soit leur nationalité
d'ailleurs l'entreprise doit les prendre
totalement en charge l'opération est
coûteuse puisque un expatrié revient au
moins à deux fois il n'y plus cher qu'un
sédentaires elles l'avouent jamais le
groupe ne dépensera un centime pour
expatriés ses salariés les moins
qualifiés
les standardistes n'ont aucune chance de
quitter la défense sauf si elle décide
de partir seul mais là ce sera le
parcours du combattant exemple pour
travailler en italie un haut cadre doit
déjà avoir un logement
or pour obtenir un bail il faut un
permis de travail exemple il faut six
mois au moins pour obtenir le droit de
travailler en espagne et aux frontières
les douaniers exige une
or de caution pour laisser passer le
camion de déménagement dernier exemple
l'allemagne
les systèmes de retraites
complémentaires sont différents d'une
entreprise à l'autre et il faut rester
quatre ans dans la même société pour que
les points soit validé c'est qu'on
quitte et qu'ils n'ont pas et notre part
c'est un peu plus aléatoire sion était
seul en ce qui concerne le niveau réel
de revenus ou de niveau réel de vie où
on aura en fin de parcours
c'est à dire qu'on peut avoir de
mauvaises surprises les pionniers de
l'europe vont devoir s'armer d'une
calculette chevaucher les législations
étudier les documentations l'europe
sociale est loin d'être cette gare aux
désillusions pour ceux qui s'imaginent
pouvoir bouger à madrid il reste encore
la nuit et demain aux européens pour se
mettre d'accord il faut aussi que vous
sachez qu'à partir du 1er juillet c'est
la france qui présidera la communauté
européenne et qui reprendra donc la
gestion de ces gros dossiers
le bon chiffre du chômage en mai la
diminution est de 0,7 pour cent elle
prolonge la baisse observée depuis le
début de l'année il y a désormais moins
de 10% de la population active
demandeurs d'emploi en france avec 2,2
millions 516 milles 800 chômeurs la
france se rapproche de la moyenne
européenne
cette nouvelle baisse du chômage est
essentiellement due à la reprise de la
croissance en 88 qui fait sentir tous
ses effets le financement des partis
c'est le refrain en ce moment dans le
monde politique industrielle l'actualité
ce soir dans un jugement du tribunal
correctionnel de montpellier
le promoteur bordelais andré orta a été
condamné à quatre ans de prison ferme et
1 million de francs d'amendé il reste en
détention accusé de faux en écriture
publique pour avoir détourné près de 70
millions de francs
l'inculpé a toujours dit pour sa défense
qu'il finançait les partis politiques
pascal deschamps homme discret andré
orta emporte avec lui dans sa cellule de
la prison nîmoise des secrets que son
procès n'aura pas permis de révéler car
s'il a avoué avoir financé les campagnes
électorales avec de l'argent détourné
il a toujours refusé de trahir les
bénéficiaires le mécanisme utilisé en
revanche a été mise à nu le promoteur
bordelais avaient été chargés de
construire un palais des congrès par la
ville de carcassonne qui devait lui
obtenir un prêt de 71 millions andré
orta l'a bien reçue large
non mais le centre est resté à l'état de
maquette en juillet 88 les entreprises
de construction impayés arrêtait les
travaux pour dépenser ses 70 millions
andré orta avait trouvé mieux ailleurs
pour ses avocats le tribunal de
montpellier a été dans cette affaire
d'une extrême sévérité
comme si distille temps substance la
justice en avait rajouté à quelques mois
de l'examen d'un projet d' amnistie sur
le financement occulte des partis
justement le gouvernement a finalement
décidé de reporté à la session d'octobre
le projet de loi sur le financement de
l'activité politique
vous savez que ce projet comporte
également une amnistie des délits qui
imbrique la politique et les finances
dans l'entourage de michel rocard
on dit qu'il faut de la sérénité pour
examiner un texte qui aurait pu venir en
discussion
dès la session extraordinaire de juillet
plus de sérénité mais aussi gilles
leclair plus d'inconfort semble-t-il
pour le gouvernement au cas où la
sagesse l'emportent donc sur le risque
ce soir c'est après une dernière
conversation avec françois mitterrand
que michel rocard a donc tranché pour
une discussion à l'automne il est vrai
que les conditions pour le succès de ce
projet n'était pas aujourd'hui
franchement réunis aux yeux de matignon
le climat d'abord plutôt malsain avec
les affaires de financement de partis
politiques et une justice malmenée dans
un autre dossier le dossier lüscher
ensuite raisons politiques il n'y avait
sans doute pas de majorité aujourd'hui
en ce début d'été pour voter ce texte le
gouvernement risque et même d'être
renversé par une motion de censure signe
à la fois par la droite et le parti
communiste
à l'automne le premier ministre il ira
sans doute plus clair d'abord la justice
sera suivi son cours
la miss teen n'empêchant pas d'ailleurs
les poursuites contre ceux qui se
seraient enrichis personnellement mais
surtout les socialistes pourraient
trouver d'ici là des alliés au centre
comme à l'udf partenaires éventuels ou
députés soucieux de passer l'épongé
alors si ce report provoque quelques
grimaces au sein du parti socialiste
matignon espère bien qu'à la rentrée
l'atmosphère sera plus sereine
il serait en effet temps qu'à l'heure de
la célébration de la démocratie
une vraie loi puisse faire progresser la
morale en politique plutôt que
d'assister parfois à l'enterrement de
tel ou tel dossier ou tel ou tel
scandale
sa mission et des peluches et une fois
par an les comptes de l'état des
collectivités territoriales et des
organismes qui leur sont rattachés
l'aco
des comptes publie donc son rapport
annuel palmarès 89 et passage à l'étrier
pour par exemple le palais omnisports de
bercy insuffisamment préparés trop
coûteux d'exploitation difficiles avec
études préalables bâclé c'est dans le
rapport de la cour
c'est ainsi que la cour s'étonne que par
exemple le parking ne compte que sept
cent cinquante places alors que la salle
du pays aux bébés comme on l'appelle en
compte l 17000 autre exemple les
charbonnages de france qui sont
également mis à l'index qui ont selon la
cour dépenser trop d'argent dans la mise
en place des reconversions nécessaire
jean-pierre métive et maryse mano
peut-être la dernière image des temps
héroïques
il ne reste que deux puits en activité
dans le nord les autres enfermé il a
fallu aider les départs des mineurs
celui ci est devenu cafetiers grâce à
une aide
cet autre garagiste c'est grâce à eux
d'ailleurs sur la plus faire quelque
chose sans colle au nom de paul nahon
donne pas l'argent comme soir
chaque départ a coûté 300 mille francs
bien trop cher estime la cour des
comptes qui épingle charbonnages de
france pour son volet social trop
protecteur on a demandé à l'époque à la
profession des efforts considérables
il fallait produire compte que coûte ça
n'est pas très vieux encore les gens ne
l'ont pas oublié vous ne pouvez pas
aujourd'hui au jour d'aujourd'hui parce
que les conditions économiques ont
changé certes dire eh bien merci vous
rentrez chez-vous point la vie
plus inquiétant en pleine période de
licenciement les charbonnages perdait 18
millions de francs sur des opérations de
change et entre 1982 et 85
la cour des comptes relève que le nombre
de directeurs phase de 11 à 20 leur
salaire augmente en 2 47% contre 34%
pour le personnel c'est choquant compte
tenu aussi qu'en dehors balade du
problème salarial se retrouve le
problème annexe qui sont les problèmes
de revenus en général notamment les uns
des divers avantages que bénéficie cette
hiérarchie légale par exemple il ya les
avantages en nature
keep logement voiture de service aux
autres que je ne tiens pas précisé mais
qui font l'objet de débats j'ai
important et historique dans notre
organisation et dans l'entreprise
sur ces broutilles ces petits fonds
perdus les syndicats rejoignent les
limiers de la cour des comptes mais pas
sur le coup du social bien entendu quant
à la direction elle jure que tout ça
c'est de l'histoire ancienne
la grève des auxiliaires de puériculture
dans les crèches parisiennes s'est
poursuivie aujourd'hui 67 crèche
marseillaise ont également été paralysé
par une action de 24 heures des
directrices et sous-directrice
essentiellement actions essentiellement
lié à des questions salariales
les sénateurs ont discuté cet après-midi
de la présidence unique à la tête des
chaînes publiques chaîne de télévision
antenne 2 et fr3 le rapporteur rpr du
projet monsieur gouteyron propose deux
amendements qui vise purement et
simplement à supprimer les deux articles
du projet de loi argumentation dur à
porter ce projet ne résoudra pas la
crise du secteur public
décodage avec olivier werner je suis
forcément aux acteurs j'allais dire
professionnels un sénateur qui zappe et
qui rapportent dans un débat pour
sénateur a peur c'est plutôt rare
contrairement aux épisodes précédents
jack lang était aux côtés de catherine
tasca pour défendre la réforme de
l'audiovisuel public
le ministre place la barre très haut et
se montre optimiste sur l'effet zapping
entre chaînes privées et chaînes
publiques
l'objectif c'est que l'année prochaine
notre télévision publique retrouve une
part d'audience comprise entre 40 et 50%
au moins harmonisation cohérence droite
et gauche se retrouvent sur ce terrain
mais quand le gouvernement parle
présidence commune l'opposition répond
recul de l'indépendance des schémas très
grande majorité d'entre nous souhaitent
pressante année au comité de
coordination prévu dans l'exposé des
motifs
en jouant son rôle de passerelle entre
les deux chaînes il serait tout aussi
efficace et beaucoup plus ou et ils ne
comprendraient pas les inconvénients que
je vais dénoncer mais pour cela pour
créer ce comité
nul besoin d'une loi et nous vous
pouviez faire l'économie de ce débat
l'issue de ce débat mené devant des
fauteuils vides ne faisait aucun doute
le projet du gouvernement n'a pas été
adopté au sénat pas vraiment une
surprise
pas vraiment de quoi en tout cas
réveillés le seul photographe en série x
pas de quotidiens nationaux demain dans
les kiosques que le comité intersyndical
du livre cgt annonce une grève de 24
heures
motivé par le refus des conséquences
sociales des plans de modernisation des
ateliers d'imprimerie
nouvelle pierre à l'édification des
accords de matignon sur la nouvelle
calédonie simon loueckhote mélanésiens
rpcr donc anti indépendantistes a été
élu président du congrès du territoire
il n'a que 32 ans mais beaucoup
d'expérience et de sens politique
bruno roger petit simon loueckhote le
dauphin a consacré simon loueckhote
fidèle compagnon de jacques lafleur
désormais président du congrès de
nouvelle calédonie un an jour pour jour
après les accords matignon entre rpcr
effet lengas rpcr fnca est plus que
jamais dominant sur la scène
calédoniennes les loyalistes ont même
concédé trois des huit vice présidence
du congrès aux indépendantistes une
nouvelle étape est donc franchie comme
michel rocard s'y était engagé le
calendrier néo calédonien et jusque là
respecté
prochaines étapes à venir dès le 14
juillet prochain
l'état cédera le pouvoir exécutif sur le
territoire à simon loueckhote 1998 temps
suit date prévue pour le référendum
d'autodétermination qui décidera oui ou
non de l'indépendance de la nouvelle
calédonie mais aujourd'hui les esprits
étaient encore penché sur un passé
proche et douloureux premiers gestes du
nouveaux président du congrès une minute
de silence en l'honneur des morts de
tous les morts de nouvelle calédonie
1200 détenus sont sortis aujourd'hui de
prison en vertu de la grâce ce
présidentiel signé le 16 juin dernier
d'ici au 14 octobre 3091 détenus
bénéficieront de cette mesure de
clémence prises dans le cadre du 14
juillet à l'étranger la hongrie et sa
révolution tranquille ou si l'on préfère
sa marche vers la démocratie
parlementaire
l'an prochain il y aura là bas des
élections libres les premières depuis
en attendant ce week end le parti
communiste s'est donné un président et
une direction collégiale
mais attention caractéristiques
essentielles se sont tous ou presque des
réformateurs
jacques merlyn
c'était il y a un an
yannos cadart passer la main après 32
années de direction du parti communiste
hongrois il laissait la place à caroline
rose âgée de 59 ans celui-ci danse est
alors une vaste série de réformes
politiques et économiques avec certes un
geste hautement symbolique comme la
destruction du rideau de fer entre la
hongrie et l'autriche ou encore la
réhabilitation d'imre nagy
l'homme qui était à la tête de
l'insurrection de budapest en 1956 le 16
juin de cette année deux cent mille
hongrois assistaient à cette cérémonie
officielle de nantes une sépulture digne
à celui qui le 16 juin 1958 fut pendue
et enterré à ce contre terre mais quand
on est grosse a été dépassé par le
rythme effréné de réformes qu'il avait
lui même déclenché et ce week-end le
comité central du parti à renier ses
pouvoirs en mettant en place un
présidium de quatre membres
dominés par des partisans une
accélération de ses réformes
l'homme fort du régime maintenant c'est
lui résonné hier c'est sous son
influence qu il a été décidé d'organiser
des élections véritablement libres l'an
prochain en hongrie avec l'idée que le
parti communiste pourrait être l'une des
composantes seulement d'un gouvernement
de coalition
le financier umberto ortolani bras droit
du grand maître de la loge maçonnique
clandestine p2 pourra bénéficier d'une
remise en liberté après le versement
d'une caution de deux millions cinq cent
quatre-vingt mille francs c'est une
décision de la justice milanaise
cet homme était l'un des hommes clés
encore vivants de l'un des plus grands
scandales italien des années 70 hervé
brusini le petit moustachu
c'est ainsi qu'on le surnomme umberto la
niveau 90 millions de dollars
cet argent il leur ait empoché sur la
police italienne après le krach du banco
ambrosiano la faillite qui fit chanceler
les finances du vatican il y a dix ans
cet ancien chef de gare était devenu
l'ami des plus hautes autorités de la
curie romaine
une amitié d'affaires après sept années
de villégiature d'auray passé au brésil
il est revenu au pays pour se rendre
mais ils étage
et en mauvais santé affirment ses
avocats alors on vient de le remettre en
liberté contre une caution de 300
millions de francs les vrais ortolani
c'est peut-être le cerveau financier de
la loge p2 sur cette photo il est aux
côtés de celui que l'on qualifié de
grand maître de la loge licio gelli
et lui aussi est à présent liberté il
donne des conférences de presse
vend des livres menace de faire des
révélations qui ne viennent jamais la p2
et ses ambitions de coup d'état la paix
deux essais lien probable avec les
terroristes de l'extrême droite comme à
bologne où l'attentât avait fait 85
morts plus question d'en parler pour le
moment
comme si la justice italienne avait
passé un pacte avec les rares survivants
de la faire rare puisque roberto calvi
un autre financier a été retrouvé pendu
sous un pont de londres
michele sindona un banquier également
impliqué est mort lui fâcheusement
empoisonné par une tasse de café
aujourd'hui on se donnerait donc à
évoquer les affaires d'argent pas celles
qui relèvent de la politique
l'instruction est sur le point d'être
close et monseigneur martin kusch devenu
depuis gouverneur du vatican attend avec
ses amis de comparaître devant la
justice
un jour peut-être philippe la suite de
l'actualité l'étranger la grèce toujours
sans gouvernement les états unis où la
cour suprême admet la peine de mort pour
les mineurs la chine normalisée et cuba
où les héros tombe pour trafic de drogue
éric perrin
le général cubain arnaldo ochoa passible
de la peine de mort ochoa est accusé
d'avoir participé à un trafic de drogue
pour le compte du cartel de medellin
ainsi qu'à de la contrebande d'ivoire et
de diamants le ministre de la défense
raul castro le frère de fidel castro a
demandé une condamnation exemplaire
les états américains peuvent infliger la
peine de mort aux assassins qui n'était
âgé que de 16 ou 17 ans au moment des
faits la cour suprême des etats unis
on a décidé insisté
l'état de santé d'andréas papandréou
toujours hospitalisés s'améliore
lentement
l'absence du président de la république
grecque qui représente son pays au
sommet européen de madrid prolonge de
fait le délai accordé à monsieur
papandréou pour former un gouvernement
il a dans ce cas avoir rencontré le
leader des communistes dans sa chambre
d'hôpital
la propagande s'intensifie en chine où
la télévision assène ses images de pouye
et d'arrestations le colonel lee et yang
a réaffirmé devant des journalistes
étrangers
la version officielle selon laquelle
aucun étudiant avait été tué lors de
l'intervention de l'armée sur la place
tiananmen le 4 juin dernier
justement pour ne pas oublier cette
normalisation de main à la sorbonne à
paris aura lieu de 18h à 20h un colloque
avec notamment robert badinter président
du conseil constitutionnel sur le thème
quelle solidarité avec les étudiants
chinois
la sécheresse toujours le spectre de
1976 se précise une réunion pour mettre
au point les mesures d'urgence est
organisée jeudi au ministère de
l'agriculture
essentiellement dans l'ouest de la
france les mesures de restriction sont
de plus en plus draconiennes ne pas
arroser sa pelouse ne pas laver sa
voiture au kazoo ne pas remplir sa
piscine
le monde agricole est bien sûr très
inquiet même si pour l'instant
raymond lacombe président de la fnsea
affirme qu'il ne demandera pas
l'instauration d'un nouvel impôt
sécheresse
ce soir nous voyons avec josé blanc
lapierre comment l'on peut préserver son
jardin du clim hortensias et roses
trémières en un mois d'avancé
ce jardin des bords de marne n'a pas
connu divers plantes et arbustes ont
poussé prématurément et en tant que
c'est un coup de chaleur en mai résultat
une végétation mal enracinée et fragile
aujourd'hui c'est de l'eau qu'il lui
faut beaucoup d'eau alors que faire
quand elle est rationnée c'est tout
d'abord utilisé les moyens modernes que
les jardiniers ont à leur disposition
des sound arrosage particulièrement qui
permettent d'apporter l'eau au niveau
des racines des grosses plantes des
arbres et des arbustes donc une économie
d'eau car l'eau ne s'évapore pas comme
si on la laissait simplement surface
même dans une cuvette
deuxièmement vous biner car vous savez
qu un binage vaut deux arrosages et vous
payez avec des écorces de pin broyer du
compost végétal de la paille des
feuilles lorsqu'il s'agit des petits
semis de début d'été
il faut bien sûr bien les tenir frais au
pied pour permettre que le soleil ne
tape pas directement sur les graines et
là elles vont beaucoup mieux géré
m'élever et vous arroser un petit peu
bien sûr sur ses feuilles de fougères
pour les plantes d'appartement une bonne
bush ont percé diffusera l'eau goutte à
goutte fraîcheur garantie avec de la
tourbe l'humidifier régulièrement faute
d'arrosage vaporiser mais le soir
seulement
quant à la pelouse mieux vaut la laisser
jaunir un arrosage de surface lui
apporte quantité de racine qui finissent
par l'étouffer le gazon est solide aux
premières pluies comme le désert il
reverdira tennis wimbledon c'est parti
c'est très très sec qualifiés du premier
tour hedberg lendl entre autres claude
et m'a pas vraiment facile ce premier
tour pour le numéro un mondial ivan
lendl accroché sérieusement même par un
jeune vénézuélien nicolas pereira
herrera classé 108e mondial mais tout de
même champion du monde junior 88 7 6 4 6
6 3 6 7 6 1 pour le type autobacs qui
rencontrera batman un américain au
deuxième tour en revanche aucun problème
pour stefan edberg tête de série numéro
2 facile vainqueur du canadien breedam
6/3 6/4 qualifié également becker
connors pernfors ivanisevic qui a dominé
thierry champion
déçus les dames isabelle de manger
karine qu'un traître et monica seles
quant à michael chang le héros de roland
garros il joue en ce moment même contre
scanlon un américain bon serveur classé
251e mais chuck s'adapte bien au gazon
il monte même à la volée est ce la fin
de vie réussir il vient de remporter les
deux premiers sets 6 4 6 3 la pub à
cannes nous 36e festival international
du film publicitaire les anglais et les
américains ont raflé la plupart des
titres comme d'habitude mais les
français le zimbabwe l'ex rhodésie et
l'espagne sont rentrés avec quelques
lion d'or c'est la récompense
regardez d'ailleurs ce spot espagnol
primés vous y découvrez un chien qui
n'aiment pas la télé et qui aimerait que
son maître s'occupe encore plus de lui
mais rien n'y fait le gamin préfère la
télé ce spot a été commanditée par nos
confrères espagnols
stefan mani
casio washington match tenchu lynch tel
aviv 100 blé people ce petit chien
andalou a parfaitement réussi à faire
passer les deux messages dans télé le
porter
la télévision espagnole qui conseille
aux enfants de ne pas être trop télé
dépendants et la montée des nouveaux
créateurs publicitaire face au roi du
genre que sont depuis toujours les anglo
saxons cette année l'espagne a reçu 25
récompenses dont la palme d'or juste
derrière les états unis la grande
bretagne et devant la france alors qu'il
ya quatre ans elle n'avait obtenu que
trois prix mais ont aussi on a assisté à
l'arrivée de nouveaux venus aussi
inattendue que singapour ou comme ici le
zimbabwe la production télévisée est en
train de se développer dans chaque pays
les 3650 et un film venu de 50 nations
différentes hommes ont fait la
démonstration ce week-end cela permet de
découvrir la tendresse où l'humour lui
par d'autres cultures qui s'en plaindre
à
m
voilà la pub
venus de l'afrique du sud enfin venu de
tout en bas en tout cas de la région
l'afrique du sud pronostic de pierrette
brès il ya un tiercé en nocturne mardi
27 juin sur l'hippodrome de vincennes
dans le prix talent ya dix neuf partants
voici les pronostics de pierrette le 14
le 18 le neuf le 8 le 19 le 7 le 17 le
16 voilà dans un instant vous avez
rendez vous avec laurent cabrol pour la
météo les journaux de la soirée seront
assurés par henri sannier la rédaction
d'antenne 2 vous annonce que hervé
claude et christine ockrent sont
légèrement souffrant c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous retrouverai à
cette même place demain soir à 20 heures
excellente soirée à tous